we're continuing the series on 3d world
generation and implementing planetary
level of detail that means we'll extend
the previous quadtree project into a
full-scale planet long shots from a
distance are pretty neat but wouldn't it
be even cooler if you could go further
entire planets generated on the fly with
the ability to not only see from space
but all the way to the ground in the
last tutorial we covered a way to get
level of detail using quadtrees which
increased the resolution closer to the
camera while using low resolution meshes
for far away combining that with some
sort of purlins or simplex noise and
fractional Brownian motion what I gave
us was effectively an infinite
procedural world in every direction what
we're covering today is going to expand
on that but instead of an infinite plane
in every direction we're wrapping the
terrain over a sphere giving us a planet
scale system basically we want to go
from a plane to a sphere and there's
probably a whole bunch of ways to get
this done I opted for what I thought
would be the simplest route and I'll
dynamically Tesla to cube using
quadtrees my idea being that if you
start with a cube and tessellated you
can pull the vertices into a sphere
shape so the first thing I'll be doing
is creating a new class which I'll call
the cube treat and all this will do is
manage the six sides of the cube
creating a quadtree for each one now to
get this working I want to try and just
get a single side working properly so
what I'll do first is prevent the
quadtree from creating any new children
and this will effectively just turn it
into a single plane that way I can go
into the terrain code here and it has to
be updated so that it gets not just the
children for the quadtree but all the
children for each quadri for each face
of the cube and modify any other code
that might rely on that once that's done
I can confirm it's all working by going
into the browser and all we should see
now is a single plane with terrain on it
which is what we're seeing this is
working properly and the next step will
be to get all the other sides working to
get all of the other sides rendering we
need to go back into the cube tree and
define more sides now one thing to note
here is that although the first side
rendered to get a cube we need to rotate
each of these quad trees so we'll go
ahead and add transforms
each side so that they face the
appropriate direction so for each side
we define a rotation so the quadtree
faces that access and we have positive x
negative x positive Y negative Y
positive side and negative side loading
it up they're all facing the right way
but obviously they're all centered at
the origin so next we need to go back to
the transforms redefine and we need to
translate by the radius of the sphere we
want to create and now we have a cube
let's make that into a sphere which will
serve as a base for our planet what I
did here was I rewrote the mesh
generation code because previously we
were using 3GS to generate the plane and
then we'd loop over and adjust the
height but now we need to adjust every
single vertex to sit on the surface of
the sphere and it's simpler and easier
to write our own code that just does it
in a single pass but the code here does
is generates a position on the plane and
then calculates the direction to the
origin or zero zero zero once you have
the direction you can scale the vector
by the radius of the sphere and now
you've curved this plane to the surface
of the sphere here's an example you
start with this plane here tessellated a
bit so that you have some vertices to
work with and then if you define the
center of the sphere at some distance
from the plane you can drag the vertices
towards it that's with a single face
with six faces you do the same thing and
you end up with the sphere one problem
as you might have noticed when I switch
wireframe mode off and you can see each
of the faces they're all identical just
rotated for each side of the cube the
colors for each face in other words the
landscape is identical and that's
because originally the terrain was 2d so
we only sampled the noise based on the
XY coordinate of each vertex which works
fine when the terrain is restricted to a
plane since this is a sphere now we need
to modify how we sample the noise so
that each vertex looks it up in 3d we'll
need to make modifications in a few
places the noise code needs to change to
accept 3d coordinates and we need to
pass a world space coordinate when
generating the noise back in the mesh
generation code getting world space
coordinates is really simple since it's
exactly the same transform that's
applied in the vertex shader we use the
transform defined in the cube tree which
are passed through each terrain chunk
and we apply the matrix here as the
coordinates are generated
giving us world space coordinates let's
confirm the working by transforming the
direction vector and outputting that as
a color when we load it up in the
browser we were expecting to see smooth
red green blue across the sphere which
is what we see so that means we can now
go ahead with the changes to the noise
to make it 3d this isn't that involved
since the simplex noise library has both
2d and 3d functions we just switched the
2d call for a 3d one and change a few
spots around the code that take X and Y
to add Zed and now the terrain coloring
shows up smoothly across the planet to
make the terrain height map work again
in the mesh generation code you have
this Direction vector here which defines
the direction from the center of the
sphere to the vertex on the plane if you
scale this by the height at that point
and add it to the vertex you end up with
a height map sphere okay so the sphere
is working the terrain is properly
height mapped and the coloring is all
working again
the last step here is to get the
quadtree working again so that we get
level of detail depending on the
position of the camera the first thing
we want to do here is add an easy way to
debug this so we're separating out the
camera that's used to view from the
camera that's used for level of detail
so as we create the terrain we create
this fake user camera that's passed in
and the Train uses that to decide what
to do level of detail I'll also
instantiate a little sphere where that
camera is so that we know where it is
and we can visualize it to get the
quadtree working again we'll go back and
turn it on and allow it to create child
nodes again surprisingly was just that
we kind of get some results although
this is pretty broken the problem is
that we're not using the offset of each
quadtree node when generating the
vertices so in the mesh generation code
this amounts to adding the offset to the
vertex before we map it back to the
surface of the sphere if we modify the
little sphere to orbit the planet a bit
you'll notice that the level of detail
calculations seem to be pretty off
they're not happening where you'd expect
which is right by the sphere the reason
is that each side of the cube each quad
tree calculates the distance from the
node to the position of the camera but
this is all done in their local space
these calculations now need to be done
in the same space so an easy fix here is
to
create a sphere Center for each node and
that's the world space center and that's
done by applying the local to world
transform to bring it into world space
and then mapping it to the sphere
surface again like we do with the
vertices once that's done we can see
that the level of detail now seems to be
coming in right where that little sphere
is you can see a lot of resolution right
by where that little sphere is and then
the rest of the planet is pretty low
resolution so this is working properly
and so there we have it we modified our
previous quadtree implementation to do
level of detail over an entire planet
and I can modify the size of this planet
however big or small I want see I can
just jack up the radius here and we end
up with a much larger planet and we can
zoom in and we retain the detail all the
way to the surface source code is all
available on github so go ahead and fork
it and tweak it or add to it do whatever
you want with it
make sure to hit like and subscribe and
I'll see you next time Cheers